[Aplausos]
[Música]
llega el domingo y típico de argentinos
nos juntamos en una casa comer un asado
todo genial hasta que después empieza el
problema de cómo está cocida la carne en
mi caso particular con mi papá siempre
discutimos de que yo la como demasiado
como suela de zapato y yo considero en
realidad que él la come demasiado cruda
seguramente esto se repite en muchas
familias y en muchos almuerzos de amigos
pero existe un punto ideal de cocción de
la carne y si dejamos de lado los gustos
hay un punto correcto de cocción de la
carne
soy biotecnóloga y les voy a costar
contar muchas cosas interesantes
escucharon hablar de la contaminación
cruzada es el procedimiento por el cual
los alimentos se contaminan con
sustancias que les son ajenas y muchas
veces nocivas para la salud
un caso típico es cuando uno corta carne
cruda y luego con los mismos utensilios
corta carne cocidas verduras o pan
durante el proceso de faenamiento la
carne suele estar contaminada con
bacterias propias del intestino de la
vaca si la carne no está bien cocida
puede que estas bacterias no hayan sido
eliminadas esto es peligroso y precisan
principalmente para los niños menores de
5 años porque son propensos a
desarrollar el síndrome urémico
hemolítico
el síndrome urémico hemolítico se da por
la ingesta de carne mal cocida verduras
más lavadas aguas contaminadas jugos y
lácteos no pasteurizados argentina
representa el principal es el principal
país en el mundo de índice de síndrome
urémico hemolítico y hoy en día no hay
vacunas ni tratamientos específicos por
lo cual la prevención es fundamental y
si esto vale para los cortes de carne
enteros esto es especialmente importante
para la carne picada si uno tiene un
corte de carne entero el interior no
estuvo expuesto a contaminaciones sin
embargo la carne picada en su totalidad
estuvo expuesto a contaminantes por
ejemplo las cuchillas la cortada la
picadora de carne las manos del operador
por lo cual tiene una superficie
significativamente superior que estuvo
expuesta a contaminaciones y que puedan
tener agentes que produzcan enfermedades
como les mencioné el síndrome urémico
hemolítico se da luego de la ingesta de
alimentos contaminados pero contaminados
con qué
se asocia al síndrome urémico hemolítico
con la bacteria escherichia coli
productora de toxina shiga pero en
realidad esta bacteria
es como un caballo de troya dentro de su
adn se encuentra un bacteriófago y
dentro del bacteriófago se encuentra la
toxina shiga que es la responsable
principal de desarrollar el síndrome
urémico hemolítico ya que una vez en
circulación se une a los órganos blancos
que son el riñón y el cerebro
produciendo daños irreversibles
escucharon hablar de los bacteriófagos
son virus bacterianos que están dentro
de una bacteria en condiciones normales
se replican junto a la bacteria sin
ocasionarles daño alguno sin embargo
bajo condiciones de estrés como pueden
ser el pasar del intestino de la vaca al
intestino de un ser humano
en la leen e del bacteriófago sale del
adn bacteriano y empieza a replicarse
de esta manera mata a la bacteria y es
capaz de infectar otras bacterias
intestinales
los bacteriófagos son fantásticos yo la
verdad que soy fanática de ellos desde
que empecé a trabajar son las unidades
biológicas más numerosas del planeta se
considera que hay 10 a la 31
bacteriófagos y se los encuentra en
todos lados hasta el fondo del mar para
que tengan una estimación la población
mundial es de 7.500 millones de personas
esto es 75 y 80 bacteriófagos hay
10 10 a la 31 esto es 10 30 ceros es
hasta imposible de decirlo y como se
pueden imaginar al haber tantos los hay
buenos y los hay malos en el caso del
síndrome urémico hemolítico estamos
hablando de un bacteriófago malo ya que
causa ya que produce una toxina que
causa una enfermedad pero también hay
bacteriófagos buenos los que son capaces
de infectar bacterias que son
multirresistentes y de esta manera
controlar infecciones bacterianas
soy investigadora y estoy trabajando
específicamente en terapias para
combatir el síndrome urémico hemolítico
en nuestras investigaciones demostramos
que la toxina shiga no solamente es
producida por las bacterias intestinales
sino que también por nuestras propias
células humanas
esto representa un cambio de paradigma
ya que todas las terapias estaban siendo
enfocadas solamente en la producción
bacteriana sin tener en cuenta la
producción a partir de nuestras propias
células y lo más importante es que el
bacteriófago es capaz de internalizar se
en una célula humana pero no la infecta
es decir el bacteriófago no se replica
esto es lo que nos permite es abrir una
nueva etapa en lo que es tratamientos
del síndrome urémico hemolítico pero
también contra otras enfermedades que
son producidas por toxinas que están
codificadas por bacteriófagos
como por ejemplo difteria cólera entre
otras en todos estos casos estábamos
hablando como les dije bacteriófagos
malos que producen enfermedades
pero también están los bacteriófagos
buenos
que son posibles de controlar
infecciones con bacterias
multirresistentes las que se llaman
súper bacterias
quien no ha comprado antibióticos sin
receta el mal uso de los antibióticos
provoca y sigue provocando la aparición
de bacterias que son multirresistentes y
que son imposibles de controlar con los
antibióticos disponibles
actualmente esta tecnología se encuentra
en fase clínica en muchos países del
mundo pero para ser sincera esta
tecnología no es novedosa se remonta a
la exunión soviética
el instituto de oliva es el instituto
más reconocido a nivel mundial y fue
fundado en 1923 en la actual georgia
este instituto tiene asociado una
clínica a la cual van personas de todo
el mundo pues en el único lugar que se
permite este tipo de terapia van
personas con infecciones con bacterias
multirresistentes como también van
personas que tienen infecciones crónicas
pero ahora sí en esta tecnología este
hace 100 años porque hoy en día su uso
todavía no se encuentra regulado en el
resto del mundo
después de muchos años sin estudios
referidos al uso de los bacteriófagos
buenos para controlar enfermedades su
vuelta a la fama se vio impulsada por la
falta de nuevos antibióticos y no
solamente eso se vio impulsada por el
departamento de defensa de los eeuu
poder combatir bacterias
multirresistentes es de interés de los
departamentos de defensa de los de los
países desarrollados nosotros desde una
universidad conurbano tratamos de
aportar al desarrollo de esta plataforma
para poder combatir infecciones con
súper bacterias
y refiriéndome a las superbacterias el
caso de éxito que dio lugar a la empresa
del doctor merrill de quien les hablaré
luego fue de un norteamericano que en un
viaje de vacaciones egipto junto a su
mujer se infectó con una bacteria su
súper resistente una súper bacteria
y su mujer al ser epidemióloga logró que
tanto la fed layers navy el doctor
merrill y otros científicos se pusieran
la cura de este hombre al hombro
escribieron un libro de todo lo que
vivieron y de todo lo que lograron a
partir de combatir esta infección pero
hay un segundo uso aún más fantástico de
los bacteriófagos y es la capacidad que
tienen de ingresar a las células humanas
sin infectar las esto nos permite
utilizarlos como vehículos para
tratamiento personalizado de muchas
enfermedades por ejemplo se lo puede
utilizar como vehículo vacunal o como
vehículo para tratar enfermedades como
cáncer y aún más novedoso en fagot en
terapia génica si bien todo esto parece
ciencia ficción cada uno de estos temas
están siendo abordados en diferentes
laboratorios del mundo
en su momento cuando junto a mi grupo de
trabajo demostramos que la toxina shiga
era capaz de ser producida por nuestras
propias células nos habían aparecido
resultados muy extraños y digo extraños
porque representaban un cambio de
paradigma de lo que se conocía respecto
al síndrome urémico hemolítico
entonces busque bibliografía que pudiera
avalar lo que estábamos observando
solamente encontré dos trabajos donde
mostraban que un bacteriófago era capaz
de ingresar a una célula humana y una
vez dentro de ella si tenía un promotor
reconocible nuestras propias células
podrían producir una proteína del
bacteriófago o una proteína que nosotros
querramos guau deje yo y encima eran
trabajos del año 71 y el año 72 en
revistas internacionales excelentes y
las dos habían sido publicadas por la
misma persona el doctor merrill
nos pusimos en el trabajo de dar a
conocer nuestro trabajo pero no fue
fácil nuestro trabajo representaba un
cambio de paradigma
también había solamente dos trabajos que
avalaban lo que estábamos observando y
además habían sido desarrollados por un
grupo argentino en una universidad del
conurbano lamentablemente las revistas
internacionales miran esas cosas
en resumen tuvimos que enviarlo a siete
revistas para que pueda ser publicado
ahora que ya llevo varios años
trabajando en el tema resulta un poco
más fácil que nos crean
a pocos días de estar el artículo libre
en la web recibe un mail nada más y nada
menos que el doctor merrill
el autor que les comenté era como sea un
fanático del fútbol de escribiera me si
no no lo podía creer él estaba muy
contento porque yo había podido seguir
una línea de trabajo que él en los 70 no
había podido por falta de metodologías
correctas las líneas muertas en ciencia
no existen puede ser que se hayan
abandonado por falta de recursos por
conflictos de intereses por cuestiones
políticas o en este caso por falta de
metodologías por eso no es bueno pensar
a la ciencia solamente desde un criterio
utilitarista
calma reel hoy está jubilado es el
mérito del national institute of health
hijo y fundó junto a su hijo una empresa
de pago terapia lo que hacen es buscar
bacteriófagos de manera personalizada
para poder controlar infecciones con
super bacterias
hace poco más de un año tuve la suerte
de conocerlo viaje a eeuu y estuve con
él en su casa junto a su esposa alice y
su perro rock y compartimos una ponencia
en el congreso de washington específico
de 'fargo' terapia y fue un lujo que me
pude dar por seguir una hipótesis
diferente
tanto él como su mujer prácticamente
quisieron adoptar me querían que me vaya
a trabajar con él a la empresa de fao
terapia y montar un laboratorio de
investigación y desarrollo que aún no
tienen
la verdad que cualquiera diría que sí y
estaría instalado ya muchos de mis
colegas me decían porque no te vas
pero les voy a contar algo más personal
nací en lanús me críe en florencio
varela donde siguió discutiendo todos
los domingos por el punto de cocción de
la carne con mi papá pero siempre hay
una porción bien conocida para mí soy
primera generación de universitarios
gracias al esfuerzo de mis padres
estudio en una universidad pública y
luego realicé un doctorado en conicet
posteriormente fui a hacer un
posdoctorado en boston más
específicamente en harvard pasados esos
tres años tantos mis colegas como mis
amigos me decían que era el momento
crítico sino me volvía a los tres años
no me volvía más
la verdad que era como estar en un
parque de diversiones todo lo que
necesitaba para hacer ciencia estaba al
alcance de mi mano pero decidí volver
aplique al sistema de repatriación y
volví en el 2012
soy investigadora adjunta de conicet en
la universidad nacional de josé c.paz y
soy docente de microbiología en la
universidad nacional de quilmes
la vocación científica es crítica y más
cuando hay momentos de crisis como
fueron los últimos años
y el compromiso con el científico debe
ser enorme los científicos argentinos
somos profesionales formados en la
universidad pública que hicimos nuestros
doctorados y posdoctorados con becas de
conicet u otros fondos públicos eso
representa 10 años del estado en nuestra
invierte mi versión del estado en
nuestra formación
sin tener en cuenta a aquellos que
hicieron jardín primaria y secundaria en
escuelas públicas entonces que mejor que
los científicos argentinos para trabajar
en las enfermedades y en los problemas
nuestros
si yo podría estar en el mejor país del
mundo para hacer ciencia vivir en una
ciudad segura una economía estable tener
una casa cosa que acá no tengo pero
prefiero hacer ciencia en mi país
porque cuando uno trabaja en lo que
realmente le apasiona
cuando uno sabe que está aportando a la
cura de enfermedades de los chicos y
principalmente cuando uno está formando
profesionales en las universidades
públicas dándole dándole a conocer la
importancia de la ciencia en nuestro
país y la importancia de contar con
herramientas que nos permitan combatir
nuestros propios problemas más no se
puede pedir
[Aplausos]